the Memphis Museum of Science and
History had a had planned to celebrate
Science and History this past weekend
with an all ages family-friendly quote
unquote drag show and also dance party
the festivities were set to begin at
seven in the evening and then continue
until 11 at night there would be along
with the cross-dressers a full bar you
know people drinking drinking until they
have their fill of course to normal
non-groomer adults it's already wildly
inappropriate to invite small children
to a late night dance party with alcohol
and that would be true even if no drag
queen showed up I mean with the possible
exceptions of wedding receptions I
suppose but even then you know young
kids are going to go home before 11 at
night but maybe aside from those it's
hard to think of a scenario where it
would be acceptable to involve kids in
an event like this a dance party with
alcohol that goes to 11 at night
and why would you want to I mean what is
the non-creepy non-petophilic reason for
opening this up to children in fact
um I this is a question that um I've
been asking many of us have been asking
for for years now
I actually called the museum myself a
couple of weeks ago
and pose this question to them when I
first heard about this event they were
planning it's a simple one I mean why do
you want kids there
and also what does a drag dance party
have to do with science or history now
as to the latter question the woman on
the other end of the line who initially
told me that she could answer any
question I might have about the event
she said that that drag is it's a part
of the culture and thus it's a it's a
matter of History because it's part of
culture now I wasn't especially
persuaded by that reasoning but I was
more interested in getting an answer to
the second question why do you want kids
at the event and to that she kind of
stuttered and paused and responded and I
quote
is what she said
because it's an event
why do you want kids at the event well
because it's an event
yes but why are you involving kids
at that point she actually uh she said
that actually you know it turns out that
she's not the best person to answer my
questions and she'll have to have
someone call me back
but it doesn't seem that they ever came
up with an answer to the why do you want
kids their question at least not one
that they are willing to say out loud
and I know that based on what happened
this past Friday night which was
supposed to be the day of the event the
museum ended up shutting down the drag
dance party for children at the last
minute uh blaming the presence of
allegedly armed protesters there's a
very small group of people that the
media identified as quote unquote proud
boys who came and stood peacefully
outside of the museum and this has
prompted much handwringing from the very
same people who had absolutely nothing
to say a few weeks ago when a much
larger Battalion of masked and heavily
armed antifa showed up to a drag show in
Texas confronting a peaceful group of
protesters there now in that case there
was no problem at all but now it's a big
deal in any case the event was canceled
and the drag performers or would-be drag
performers that night anyway expressed
their frustration listen
I'm disappointed in Memphis I am I just
wish
I wish people were just more
knowledgeable and more
accepting I do uh particularly
disappointed I feel like when we do
things that cancel it it kind of
reinvigorates these groups to continue
the work that they're doing with
intimidating people the Memphis Museum
of Science and History hosted a summer
of Pride program celebrating the lgtbq
plus Community the drag show billed as
family friendly was supposed to be the
grand culmination Susan Gray and her
husband expressed their disapproval
displaying signs next to the American
flag on their car why does it bother you
when someone else brings their own child
to see this performance child abuse I
don't care who does it it's wrong why
are you telling people to leave when no
one asks you to tell people to leave
we're not telling people to leave we're
telling people to exit the parking lot
it wasn't our decision to shut the
museum down organizer Barbie weyer
heartbroken the show won't go on Angry
mosh and MPD didn't stand up to
protesters people there's an entire
exhibit in there that's about the
history of police removing queer people
from spaces of a country that does not
want us to exist of a culture that does
not want us to exist and so tonight
proves that we are still living as a
part of that history
you know it's obvious from the tone of
the questioning that the local NBC
affiliate has chosen a side they've
sided with uh the drag groomers but even
so they inadvertently provided a very
telling contrast because on the one hand
you had a normal middle-aged woman who
has taken the exceedingly rational
stance that child sexual abuse is
unacceptable
even if the parents are involved in fact
the parents involvement makes it worse
if anything
certainly not better
on the other hand you have a man in a
literal clown wig with Insane Clown
Posse face paint strutting around in a
woman's dress babbling that he's being
oppressed because he's not allowed to
dance for a bunch of kids at a science
museum
now it's up to each of us as individuals
to decide whose side we prefer to be on
here
but you notice that still none of the
people involved were able or willing to
engage with the one Central complaint
that the protesters have namely that the
event involves children okay nobody is
showing up to protest adult-only drag
shows those happen all the time in this
country no protesters footage from
adult-only drag shows never go viral
with people on the right outraged about
it
these uh female mocking Minstrel shows
have existed in this in this country for
decades and they were never a major
issue until they got the kids involved
in a society Rife with anti-religious
ideologies like the ones we hear from
the left on a daily basis it can be
incredibly challenging to ground oneself
in what we know to be true and good to
keep from descending into distrust
frustration or even hatred that's why I
find God's peace every day through
prayer and meditation with hello hello
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the U.S and the number one Catholic
app in the world it's rooted in Catholic
tradition but it's an amazing resource
for any Christian looking to dive deeper
into their prayer life hello has prayers
and meditations to guide you through
your entire day morning tonight some of
the most popular prayers include the
daily Rosary Gospel reading and daily
Psalm with Bishop Baron minute
meditations are also popular meditations
for Sleep kids prayers and so much more
hallow helps me find peace and calm
throughout the day helps me sleep better
as well lowering my anxiety levels and
so many other benefits so let hello help
you find your peace and strengthen your
faith all you got to do is go to
hello.com Matt Walsh get an extended
three month free trial during which I'll
have access to all five thousand
meditations and prayers that's hello.com
Matt Walsh for three months free reclaim
your piece in this crazy world download
hello today now I personally think that
all drag shows are weird and ugly and
bad and degrading but even I wouldn't be
talking about them if they simply left
the kids out of it
is that too much to ask
I mean go ahead and dress up like some
kind of weird sexualized Muppet and
prance around on stage lip syncing to
Lady Gaga songs go ahead and do that
just do it out of sight where I don't
have to see it and most importantly kids
don't have to see it that's all we're
asking
and it proves to be too much
it was certainly too much for the drag
show over in Chattanooga this weekend as
Tennessee
continues unfortunately to be involved
in these kinds of issues and all of the
worst ways Robbie Starbuck provided
footage of this um all ages drag
spectacle that again happened on the
same weekend
and it's some of the most disturbing
that we've seen so we'll watch on this
and I'll have to narrate it because it's
there's not a lot of audio but let's
play this clip
so you see there
dressed like a little mermaid
a child is
[Music]
stroking his general area
[Music]
and then we've got another
one okay here's another drag guy
here's the move you always see the up
spreads his legs open for the kids
kids are standing there totally confused
well there's a kid sitting at the bar
nothing wrong with that right
[Music]
and then this guy dressed like a fat
Poison Ivy from Batman walking around
and the kids are just like the kids are
not into it they don't know why they're
there
look they walk away yo look the girl's
hiding behind her mom
all right it turns off
I mean that ended up being the most
telling moment in that in the clip is
that uh this guy is walking around the
kid hides behind her mom she does not
want to be there she's like who the hell
is this guy I don't want to talk to this
guy
so to recap
there's a man in a little mermaid outfit
um who uh you know there's not even any
time to make any jokes about black
mermaids because uh the the more
relevant fact is that he's standing
there as a young child rubs his crotch
now obviously the child has no idea what
she's doing she's just a kid she sees
the sequence you know a little mermaid
outfit but he realizes what she's doing
and he makes no attempt to stop her just
stands her another man spreads his leg
for the legs for the children attendees
and then another one walks around
through the crowd slowly terrorizing
each child individually
now it's obvious when you watch this
kind of footage that these are not drag
events where kids just happen to be
attending
which would be bad enough
rather the whole point of the event is
to expose an indoctrinate kids and it's
not like there's any entertainment value
otherwise these are just pudgy guys who
can't sing or dance I can't do anything
just kind of like sauntering around
looking like creatures from Pan's
Labyrinth occasionally molesting a child
as they walk by
why though what's the point
nobody involved will explain why they
want the kids there why in fact they
structure the entire event around the
involvement of kids
that's because the answers are all
things they won't say out loud it's not
that they don't have an answer is that
they won't say it
now we know of course at the main point
and the most Sinister is to sexualize
the kids Rob them of their innocence but
there's more to it even than that
these drag performances are gaudy and
ugly
and the left as we know hates Beauty and
they seek to condition us from the
youngest ages to idolize ugliness this
and it really it it works because this
is why many young people today go out of
their way to make themselves ugly
they've been brought up in a culture
that worships ugliness
and in the cult of ugliness drag is a
sacred ritual
and finally as always
the objective is to confuse
I mean that's why the Primary Emotion
you see on the faces of the kids
involved in in this sort of thing
involved against their will is confusion
they're just confused they don't
understand why they're there they don't
understand why these men are dressed
like this they don't understand any of
it
it is bewildering and disorienting and
confusing
that's how our culture wants them
because it's much easier to manipulate
and control a person when they're lost
in a fog of confusion
so ugly confused overly sexualized
this is our culture in a nutshell and
there are a few things uglier more
confused or sexualized than a drag show
so it's no wonder that the left is so
obsessed with them
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts